[Música]
bienvenidos y bienvenidas al espacio de
cultura de france 24 un retrato gigante
para alertar sobre el destino de los
niños ucranianos esta es la última obra
de j r el artista callejero francés
conocido por sus colas de fotos en
blanco y negro viajó a la ciudad de lviv
para desplegar el retrato de valeria una
niña de 5 años que llegó a polonia a
principios de marzo con su madre j r
afirma que esta niña nos recuerda por
qué luchan los ucranianos el famoso
periódico estadounidense time magazine
decidió colocarla en la portada de su
edición del 28 de marzo titulada la
resiliencia de ucrania y de una guerra a
otra hace 60 años el 18 de marzo francia
y argelia firmaron un alto el fuego tras
casi ocho años de guerra y 132 años de
colonización allanando el camino para la
independencia del país africano pero
seis décadas después las heridas siguen
abiertas nuestros colegas del canal en
francés entrevistaron a la franco rumana
alexandra
y el francés de origen argelino yanisbel
aída dos artistas que se inspiraron en
la masacre de argelinos en parís a manos
de la policía francesa el 17 de octubre
de 1961 en 2014 me convertí en francesa
nos dijeron a partir de ahora tienen que
asumir la historia de este país con sus
momentos de gloria y sus rincones
sombríos lo que me interesa es hablar de
una herida que sale dos generaciones
después porque creo que la sociedad
francesa nos enfrentamos a estas heridas
y sus
conquistas
cuando mi abuelo me habla de ello
siempre es con una gran tristeza la
herida no está cerrada de texas
luego cuando vio la película se sintió
muy orgulloso y fue mi abuelo que me
enseñó a convivir el odio no sirve para
nada
[Música]
ahora vamos con otros temas de la
actualidad cultural que marcan este mes
de marzo la vuelta de los grandes
festivales en américa latina' los
artistas se suben de nuevo a los
escenarios para hacer bailar al público
como nuestro invitado julio victoria
bienvenido muchas gracias por la
invitación usted va a tocar este sábado
26 en el festival estéreo picnic pero
antes de hablar de esto quería
preguntarle cómo se siente frente a esta
actualidad tan dura en ucrania aquí en
france 24 hemos hablado mucho de la del
impacto de la inversión rusa en ucrania
en el mundo cultural de las respuestas
de los artistas ucranianos tal como los
rusos si usted cree que al arte y los
artistas tienen un papel en los
conflictos de esta escala sí claro que
sí es una pena toda esa situación que
estamos viviendo que se está viviendo
y afecta completamente tema global tema
también musical
precisamente los artistas lo que más
queremos destacar o los músicos lo que
más queremos
mostrar ese es amor es amor es energía
es música como lo mencionamos ahorita el
festival estéreo picnic y bueno es una
situación que creo que llevaba largo y
no estar tan fácil pero bueno ahí
estaremos apoyando desde cualquier lugar
de donde podamos y afortunadamente
tenemos también buenas buenas noticias
como la vuelta de los grandes festivales
este fin de semana en colombia es el
estéreo picnic
888 bandas y artistas durante tres días
que lugar ocupa este tipo de eventos en
su vida como como dj que también tiene
la posibilidad de tocar en clubes todo
el resto del año sí eso es realmente
emocionante estéreo picnic allá es uno
de los festivales más importantes de
sudamérica
y hacer parte de este festival tener
esta gran invitación poder presentar un
formato nuevo con el que ya llevamos un
tiempo trabajando me emociona mucho es
realmente poder poder expresar todo lo
que traíamos también de pandemia un poco
como lo menciona este es un formato de
seis músicos en tarima en vivo con mucha
instrumentación instrumentación
colombiana también es completamente
dirigido al baile es un poco diferente a
lo que venía trabajando el año anterior
que estaba trabajando otros proyectos un
poco más instrumentales más teatrales
con la nueva filarmonía
es el momento de poder expresar un poco
más allá de sacar mucho material nuevo
de trabajar con estos músicos que son
increíbles son muy buenos y poder formar
todo este todo este ensamble y traerlo a
escena va a ser va a ser muy interesante
y la dimensión visual de este nuevo show
se puede hablar un poquito también de
esto como la relación con las imágenes
con los vídeos sí para mí siempre ha
sido muy importante
ese trabajo es un es una sinergía muy
fuerte yo soy muy visual y siempre me ha
gustado mucho recurrir y buscar como
otro tipo de experiencias salirnos un
poco de la pista en algunos momentos
buscar un poco más la teatralidad
a buscar un poco más que la música sea
mucho más cinematográfica también en
esta ocasión hay mucha explosión hay
mucha explosión hay mucha iluminación
hay velocidad
hay mucho atasque por decirlo así
es muy emotivo es muy emotivo es a la
pista de baile es festival muchas luces
mucha música nueva voces vienen
sorpresas por ahí también tendremos
algún invitado cantando bueno tenemos
muchas ganas de ver todo esto sí sí
muchas gracias julio victoria por
compartir este momento con nosotros no
muchas gracias por la invitación le
recordamos a la audiencia que su último
ep en valence ya está disponible y nos
despedimos con un extracto de este
proyecto de julio victoria con la nueva
fila armonía que volverán a presentarse
el 9 de julio en el teatro mayor julio
mario santodomingo en bogotá gracias por
su confianza y cuídense
[Música]